my name is Dan Smith I'm 26 years old I  have a trucking company with three  trucks that have Bill Doyle pads for the  oil companies in North Dakota  you  I think globalization is good because it  keeps people connected and sharing  information a lot easier goods and  services get transported a lot faster  and more safe and you also can track  where your stuff set  what do I worry about matter  pizza is pretty hard to beat but a good  hamburgers what I like the best  all just the ability to control my own  destiny and make decisions based on  what's going on around me and it's my  choice I just hope to be able to pay the  bills and keep expanding a little bit  and keep the two employees that I have  happy and progressing that way  australia just because i haven't been  there yet  you